Oops
[Music]
No, I don't think I'm a tattoo, including me, and I don't think I'm going to be very careful. I
think everyone is wonderful and everyone is useless.
It's impossible in principle to put the whole body
together with it, so do it with the child you want to do
tc tattoo oc wallet brown slice touchdown 1 body Come on
co2
ske react to do benatar uce
Winker Win gree
dccd head filano master pin loading
ncp car home other team a tattoo i squadron cure
Well,
I came to myself 48 years ago, right?
It's been over a year, but it's been over 50 years, but
maybe it's been about 40 years that I've been able to do professional work myself
.
Voodoo
Sweden Chongqing 4 ge 2 Party Subchain this mag Unknown
g
voodoo japanese touch spray sate the japan
to do Pampapipo still balm and t custom.
I can already wear it, and the bad spirit is 80%
, and the remaining 20% longs for its artistry. At that
ime, the image like a tattoo goal outlaw symbol was c
mmo
place.  Since I was old
, I worked in a place where all the people around me were like that, and it was
natural to be dyed in that kind of environment, so it was cheap
to accept that tattoo.
When my posture changed
and I wanted to be in the position of Hol,
I carved my friends unnecessarily and had my own thoughts.
Well, imitating tattoos.
A movie with a tattooer in the sky with a body of ice,
the moment I saw that movie
I decided by the method that it would be a moat scene,
that is
uc to do the o Kirby d 4 body design without
d stop # derenno 4 s teacher you do
Daiso sa dahime klaster 3
something so day for 3ds to do seeds  7 minutes code
sent by Ronboy boys so Body Touch en Wyndham Election chance
to Convincing people to search for and say pictures that they have never searched for, focusing on
those that are as hazy or alive as possible.  I want to be that
depressive vc, a Buddha, a strong person, the league roses,
but I don't want to express the hardships as hardships,
but I want elegance and gods in the bath art
.  I think,
for example, it's not only good if you feel uncomfortable when you fall into the
neck, but the existence of that raw neck is unpleasant, but it's not just how unpleasant it is, but it
feels something else.  If you can't come like this,
you can't really sell books like the ones
in the picture if
you pursue
realism.  The
second generation was the son of the state, isn't it?
Who asked me to do the
goldfish and I chose the design, but
there aren't many people doing the gold industry, so next time
The second one is quite plain,
I use it, isn't it? It's a car that can't be eaten even if it's baked. It's a car like that, and it's only when the
spiritual part is backed up that it's a Japanese tattoo.
There is a
peculiar tattoo style in Japan because of a certain tattoo arts conspiracy
. There is
a tattoo shape that suits the human body.
I'm sure it's
in antaga dett The agent is a member of the Levi team, and he's chewing on him
.  Is
basically that
carbon.
That carbon of the charcoal used for carbon
burns rapeseed oil and removes the soot.
I don't know what the ink is stepping on.
Then it's not permanent in the skin.
I don't even have it, but the sins
still climb even after 1000 years, so I
take it from the pine tree
to Matsuya.  There is this in it
[Music] The
soup I mentioned earlier is hardened in Mikawa, isn't it? In short, my mother is
organic, so it rots.
Because there is a policy practice,
I'm playing Otsu, a key tissue generation strap car
Mizumoto 8 c If
I'm gone
or retired, the 4th generation
will not be my son, and now my son is shipping by name
Betsy tubo c 2 Spline Zu That Form this A 250
Jeans Foro Wing and Column
Power Chinko Punks Pop 15th Genpower Volunteer pou dou
dou Oh already x Pan 2 The number of
overseas customers is increasing more than ever.
As exchanges with foreign countries have become more active, Japanese people and foreigners have come to Japan,
and
the tattoo culture is, so to speak, competing for good points in one cultural exchange.
The ducks are
importing Japanese culture by incorporating that Western culture and hiding the culture of hell.
[Music]